une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans fil dans le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous aider
avec moins d'hommes plan on est en ce
moment dans notre nouvel espace qu'on a
dénommé l'atelier après une
recommandation de nos abonnés sur
instagram c'est un espace qui est
lumineuse d'un espace dans lequel on ne
peut pas fermer les fenêtres donc la
lumière du jour en un espace qui fait du
bien et un espace dans lequel on est on
est à l'aise on est bien on est assis un
peu plus haut en mode discussions
dynamique puis si vous nous écoutez en
ce moment ben d'espacé disponible pour
réservation donc vous pouvez aller voir
sur nos sites web triple double 20
étudiants et 16 points c'est un enfant
ou nous écrire à info un commercial
studio sf point ses hommes pour avoir
plus d'informations sur nos désormais
trois espaces d'enregistrement de
podcasts sur ce site c'est incroyable
c'est une incroyable on est rendus on le
fait trop avec le mans différentes ou
studio sf alors les filles très
sensiblement c'était moins mais tout le
monde dans le même local des studios
c'est pire et il y en a trop peu vrai y
en a trois espaces et peut-être demain
aussi ce témoin mais moi j'aime pas ce
tte la lumière artificielle
non si votre image est et sera même un
mauvais appui bas mais c'est plus vrai
ces purées parce qu'ici on est lumineux
on est rassembleur c'est rassemble en
permance et rassemblant écoute écoute
dans la pharmacie rassemblant
onu
mais on a nos livres si vous voulez
venez pas plus mais
les petits bouts du le dernier jour d'un
condamné des victor hugo un bain enfants
puis avènement pourquoi voudriez pas
faire ce bref
pour inaugurer le site le premier pas de
casque dans ce nouvel espace et on avait
le grand de recevoir de noix arsenault
qui est professeur algues vertes et
laval agriculture médecine et qui
cherche à également qui s'intéressent à
la santé et au bien être général et
s'intéresse à la nutrition qui
s'intéressent à la génétique humaine qui
s'intéressent au poids à l'obésité
aux maladies cardiovasculaires
au diabète on ne parlait tous ces sujets
le sur le podcast est vraiment super
intéressant
on ne parle plusieurs fois du sur le
podcast du lien entre
lien ou non lien fait entre le four la
santé sur les stigmatisations que vivent
les personnes grosses je pense que
benoît aujourd'hui viennent nous donner
toute l'info de la manière la plus
claire la plus compréhensible possible
plus juste la plus détaillée les plus
informés c'était un grand plaisir de
recevoir ouais on est vraiment vraiment
puis on espère que vous allez aimer ça
autant deux autres juste avant de vous
laisser la conversation on va remercier
nos commentaires le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par auch lag qui
avec qui on a renouvelé en fait notre
partenariat comme fournisseur officiel
des produits alcoolisées et non
alcoolisées on vous expliquera plus tard
pour le studio servent donc si vous
louez studio venir ici le frais est
ouvert pour vous pour vous inviter qui
nous évidemment c'est la coque on a
consommé pendant les podcasts pis la
donne tu le sais j'ai arrêté de bronze
pour être autour de autour de notre
passage au chalet où est ce qu'on a le
chalet enfin
si j'arrêtais bon ça va bientôt faire de
moi il ya tout le monde qui a arrêté
boire pour le mois de février mais c'est
pas parce que le moteur est terminée il
faut perdre nos ancêtres sud pierre
schlagg dans une gamme de deux bières
sans alcool
une blonde une blanche une blanche ses
rangs des blanches sans alcool est vrai
ses rangs très serrés puis moi je suis
un grimpeur leblanc je cesse pour se
jeter les laissez moi c'était ça ma
sortes de bières préférées
puis je compte développer un fatal pour
la banque donc
testez officiel le célébrer leur j'ai pu
goûter encore tasse que cette plage non
alcoolisées et délicieuse je joue toutes
les réponses dans sa tâche par
l'instinct mais je laissais faire du
bruit blard pour essayer de couvrir les
bruits de
but est vraiment bonne je dois vraiment
bonne je vois pas tant la différence
avec une blanche et comme au même
la blonde également également et comme
agrumes et écrit
vraiment bonne quel combat et offre
carmat va changer de bière pour fixer la
guerre de l'eau j'aime vraiment voilà
j'ai pas tout le temps le goût de boire
d'alcool ainsi mettons qu'il faut
c'est moi des fois quand je prends une
bière je peux être utile c'est sa
première sur un geste une école mais le
team et on travaille en planches en
après midi après ceux qui continuent
merveilleux incroyable h lac merci à
schlague pour votre partenariat en
continu le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par roxio optio qui est une
compagnie qui me révolutionner le statu
quo d'un les compagnies de télécoms
il met à nu d'homme une histoire avec
une compagnie télécom que je vais cette
semaine et puis je vais pas la nommer
par respect pour tout le monde inclus
mais c'était pas aussi ok moi je paye un
forfait de cellulaires pour 54 pièces
par mois j'avais sidec de donner à
chaque prime moi je passe te me donnes
et là il a fallu que je sorte des
relevés pour mes impôts et donc d'aller
sur le site web puis j'ai vu existait un
forfait moins cher que celui pour lequel
je payais pour très chic de donnea place
de cette personne n'avait rien c'était
l'histoire non non même rapide et ça
faisait sept ans que je payais que même
forfait comme un cadre le livre est
forfait qui étaient deux pièces moins
cher avec 13e gala de ce libre si
morzine ça arrive pas avec option
pourquoi ça arrive pas parce qu'ils
veulent les meilleurs prix tout le temps
auxerre c'est le meilleur tri tout le
temps yop peau de free
obscur du pad astérix heroes 2
ricky module d'un mois à l'autre patrick
et modules d'une personne alors dû payer
à menchov qui va de boisons payer tout
le monde fait la même chose et vous
savez chaque de l'or sans vous et savoir
exactement vous payez pourquoi vous
ferez jamais avoir jamais l'impression
que vous devez vous battre au téléphone
avec quelqu'un pour essayer d'avoir un
gris que de la leur avec roxio vous
serez jamais des soupirants plus sur sa
clientèle sont fins son phone sont
disponibles sont rapides c'est vraiment
bon pour votre service internet utiliser
le code promo sans fil pour un mois
gratuit si vous aimez passeur pour
tourner à vote à vos vieilles par aof
mais vos joueurs vous allez adorer parce
que son incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça vole merci d'avoir fait le chemin
jusqu'à montréal pour nous parler
occitan merci invitation les gauches
scandale des commandites qui inaugure le
nouveau studio pendant les premières
invitées à avoir c'est un nouvel espace
à cet automne lorsque la lumière du jour
là c'est un parfait français revient
dans son centre
et
écoute on a parlé un petit peu avant
mais on va on va rentrer tout soudan
d'un sujet le nous a ici au sans fil
train des sujets puis sera donné demain
m me quasiment beaucoup c'est devenu un
sujet comme ric ur un vrai problème
parce que c'est un sujet controversé
quand même parce que le poids le poids
et la santé chaque fois qu'on aborde la
question où chaque fois on a abordé la
question
ben on s'est fait critiquer de l'aborder
parce que j'imagine que c'est un sujet
sensible pour beaucoup puis qu'on n'est
pas non plus des gens qui vivent la
marginalisation au quotidien petits
vivent c'est du moins ce qu'on vit avec
le privilège et la chance d'en parler
dans le podcast de l'unige suivant la
question du privilège de la minceur et
on voit revenir tantôt mais c'est pour
ça que c'est important le de recevoir
quelqu'un qui traite vraiment de
l'aspect santé scientifique derrière la
chose parce qu'on est drivée par la
science ici ou si en fait faute hier
sylvain puis on aimerait savoir sa
perspective sur un million d'affaires
fait que je sais même pas par où on
pourrait commencer cette conversation le
on pourrait commencer par le
commencement on sait ce qu'on pourrait t
j'ai regardé tu aimes tu as fait des
routes des piétons sur l'essai de
l'université laval ton ton axes de
recherche qui dans les grandes lignes
santé bien-être pis toi c'est quoi qui
totti la santé puis bien être c'est une
question de l'art qui nous touche tous
les puits quand on est tous à la
recherche de la santé et du bien-être
lépi mais toi c'est quoi qui tôt attiré
vers ce sujet là pour dire je vois en
faire ma carrière puis mon sujet de
recherche attend non mais ça ce n'est
pas bon quand on peut retourner très
loin à mon adolescence j'ai toujours été
super sportif puis
installé dans le temps le cg j'ai grandi
en abitibi pitt et c'était le sport
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait pratiquer je
te gardien de but au wok et puis il
fallait s'entraîner l'été pour faire les
grosses équipes pour jouer d'un grosse
ligue puis c'était des années 90 je dis
ben c'est ça le thé pour performer bâti
l'alimentation c'est super important
l'activité physique le fait de
s'entraîner pendant l'été puis moi j'ai
toujours été intéressé par les par les
sciences aussi particulièrement la
biologie avec le jeu de l'usaid sort de
livres sur la nutrition au pis c'est
comment bien s'alimenter pour pour bien
performer avec les concepts justement
tizio 25 500 récemment les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui mais sauvera parler mais
même si ces deux là qui venu mon mon
intérêt pour pour justement la santé
plat bien-être lapopie évidemment après
qu'un quand j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches là tuez moi j'ai fait mon bac
en biochimie puis à un moment donné
fallait faire fallait faire des stages
qui je me suis comme décidé par j'avais
vraiment trippé sur l'île les cours de
nutrition metaboli ce que j'avais eu à
cette époque l'austalie seul qu que je
danse dans lesquelles j'avais eu des
eaux le reste serait plutôt ouest est
plutôt moyen mais j'ai commencé à faire
mon stage justement je me souviens ma
deuxième année du baccalauréat en
biochimie puis j'avais j'avais contacté
un chercheur à l'hôpital laval aussi
parce que c'est juste à côté de chez
nous qu'il fallait que je fasse un stage
puis finalement j'avais contacté le
professeur jean-pierre des prix qui qui
qui a été qu'est dray qui encore
aujourd'hui un mentor pour moi qui j'ai
constaté avec lui je me souviens très
bien dire lui au début quand j'ai
commencé dans la bullet man ma première
journée de stage bâti m'avait donné une
pile de documents à lire ce seuil à peu
près ban presque une vingtaine d'années
c'était à l'époque où est ce que tu es
les articles scientifiques n'a pas des
pdf que tu que tu écoutais 26 sec
utilisait meister c'était vraiment des
articles sur du papier glacé dans des
journaux scientifiques qui dit moi je
lisais ce puis ça a été la première
exposition à
cette idée là que la relation entre le
poids puis la santé c'est vraiment pour
se
c'est vrai c'est vraiment pas comme ces
véhicules est dans l'art immédiat par
exemple lui c'est un instant un expert
international sur wii le l'obésité mais
surtout sur la distribution du tissu
adipeux que la composition corporelle
kim n'avait jamais été exposée à ce pic
en géorgie lui justement mes premiers
articles je lisais ce je me disais wow
tu sais ça fait super longtemps que je
m'intéresse à cette question là j'ai
jamais été exposées à ce message là
parce que l'obésité c'est une condition
qui très très très hétérogène il ya des
gens qui peuvent avoir un pot qui
relativement élevé mais qui sont pas
nécessairement un risque de développer
des maladies telles le l'obésité de la
façon qu'on va classifiés ceux où
l'association que le profit la santé ça
va être selon l' indice de masse
corporelle l' indice de masse corporelle
c'est essentiellement le notre poids sur
la balance / notre grandeur élevé au
grain puis il s'est dit comme ça semble
absolument
cesser encore aujourd'hui en pratique
clinique dans les lignes directrices d'à
peu près toutes les organisations
scientifique ou médicale ben il va avoir
une section sur l' indice de masse
corporelle métiers de l'eau pour ça
donne absolument aucune espèce d'idée
sur ou dans ton corps là la grèce où ce
qu'on appelle le tissu adipeux cet
organe le qui contient des cellules qui
s'appelle des adipocytes qui vont
emmagasiner le le surplus d'énergie sous
forme de triglycérides 7 ce type de gros
lot peut être distribué par exemple au
niveau des hanches des cuisses des brode
c'est surtout un profil qu'on voit qu'on
va voir chez la femme miss hausse et
passe à sarmin
quelque chose qui est mauvais pour
l'organisme
alors qu'au contraire chez l'homme elle
allait il faut accumuler beaucoup moins
de poids sur la balance pour
avoir une accumulation de tissus adipeux
à des endroits qui sont peut-être moins
désirable pour pour la santé donc par
exemple au niveau de l'abdomen donc la
grèce qu'on va appeler intra bonal ou
viscérale mais après avoir parlé du
cégep ce que j'ai
vu et j'ai vu cette chosification
physique que ces gemmes de je pense
assez simple un moment donné parce qu'il
ya comme une une
saturation maximale à laquelle dont tu
as dit peu le sous-cutanée donc au
niveau des hanches des cuisses des bras
pour accumuler de la grèce puis cette
saturation le elle arrive beaucoup plus
rapidement chez l'homme que chez la
femme et puis bon on sait surplus
d'énergie luv u qui peut pas sans trop
poser dans des endroits
désirable comme le tissu adipeux sous
cutanée il va se retrouver ce soit dans
notre abdomen puis bin plus souvent
qu'autrement et ça va se retrouver après
ça dans notre foi dans notre coeur dans
nos muscles éthique dans notre pancréas
puis c'est vraiment ce qui va causer des
dédommagements à l'organisme comme par
exemple des problèmes de cholestérol
sanguin de lipides sanguins de
sensibilité à l'insuline
d'hypertension donc cdc des phénomènes
dont avoir trouvé le ton incertaine imc
donner beaucoup plus rapidement chez
l'homme que chez la femme parce que
chez la femme il faut que la femme
moyenne accumule beaucoup plus de pour
pour avoir
autant de grains être abdominales ou au
mauvais endroit que les hommes si nous
on avait fait une étude stern adhérer
sans cesse la première fois que
j'entends ce bon ben tant mieux ça sera
déjà et puis on a fait une étude
justement qui en cache des étudiants
doctorants parce que bon après
après mon bac j'ai fait maîtrise en
kinésiologie peu après sans un docteur
en physiologie endocrine le jeune maire
de laval sous la supervision du
professeur des prix puis ben c'est ça on
avait regardé dans une grande étude qui
avait fait qu'ils s'appellent l'étude
des familles de québec pie où il y avait
des techniques d'imagerie assez
sophistiqué pour aller voir où
exactement dans le corps humain la grèce
se retrouver l'élite l'exode a
maintenant que ça avec des techniques
l'appartement graphie axial d'escattes
puis on n'était qu'à d'aller vraiment
voir avec beaucoup de détails ou est-ce
que la grèce était situé et on s'est
rendu compte que pour que les femmes
accumule autant de graisse indésirables
qu'un homme a un indice de masse
corporelle de 30 le kéké la catégorie
qu'on dit aux bases le joli 1000 mais la
femme fallait qu'elle accumule un indice
de masse corporelle jusqu'à 40 donc
s'est rendu à ses plus de l'obésité
comme de classeurs mais ces deux classes
trop longue
premièrement c'est sûr que quand on
utilise un indice de masse corporelle en
pratique clinique bien il faut savoir
que c'est ça nous donne aucune espèce
d'idée ou la grèce et accumulé be ou hey
où les problèmes de santé vont vont se
situer et puis on le voit aussi dans
lire dans les grandes études
épidémiologiques que c'est des étudiants
qui ont pris des hommes des femmes
qu'ils ont suivi pendant 10 15 20 ans
puis ont regardé c'était quoi le risque
associé
aux impôts élevés ben le plus ça va plus
on se rend compte que bêtes au jour pour
un certain indice de masse corporelle
les hommes ont toujours est plus à
risque que les fins puis souvent on va
dire comme par exemple je reviens ou aux
différentes définitions leur indice de
masse corporelle plus des catégories bon
on va dire que en 18 points 9 puis 25
c'est comme le fameux lé poids santé
entre 25 et 30 une situation de surpoids
ou d'un bon premier plan aux 30 cd
situation d'obésité le plus on se rend
compte de on fait de plus en plus de
recherches là dessus mais on se rend
compte aussi bête d'abord dans un
premier temps ce soit qui ait des
différences sexuelles que des
différences à travers différents groupes
et nicosie même que le surcoût de
l'élise indice de masse corporelle entre
25 titres en ce qu'on appelle le sur pau
finalement c'est patent associés ou au
risque de mortalité l'otan qu'on aurait
pu qu'on aurait pu penser puis une des
façons aussi qui sait si on veut
absolument des métriques le port évaluer
la l'association le poppy la santé bas
ce serait simplement de prendre un de
prendre son tour de taille et puis là on
le voit que ben peu importe leur indice
de masse corporelle avec le tour de
taille qu'ils voient comme un être une
espèce de façon qu'on ne grossière le
d'estimé où est située la la grèce si on
a beaucoup de graisse intra abdominale
ou pas ben là on peut le voir que ben
justement si on va dans des fourchettes
10ème c'est qu'ils sont très très très
élevé bas les gens qui ont une
circonférence de temps qui est faible si
on peut sûrement risque de développer
des problèmes de santé puis au contraire
aussi les gens qui apparemment aurait un
poids santé mais qui ont une
circonférence de taille élevée souvent
on va voir beaucoup de cas de diabète de
maladies cardiovasculaires et
d'hypertension artérielle se développer
chez ces gens le mind si si on s'ils ont
un poids qui est senti le don moi je
pense que c'est ça prend il faut comme
une caisse message le parce que quand on
fait jeu simple humain s'est fié sur le
pur pour évaluer l'état de s'enrichir et
flegmatique mais le petit je vous dirais
même la circonférence de temps et ce
n'est pas juste une façon détournée de
dire faut absolument estimé les risques
associés à l'obésité mais c'est juste un
exemple pour vous dire à quel point ben
c'est déjà une mesure un petit peu plus
juste le même parlement est parfaite
mais déjà un peu plus juste que c'est
exactement puis lorsqu'on combine
saubens avec des différents marqueurs de
santé
puis c'est comme par exemple du
cholestérol bondues me du métabolisme du
glucose paix de l'insuline peut-être
certains marqueurs inflammatoires baisse
à peu on peut nous aider dans notre
prédiction du risque de développer des
maladies je mesure tout ce qui tient
demain tout se met au rocher oui
absolument le tir fait pourquoi con con
qu'on accorde encore une valeur les aime
c'est qu'on est capable de mesurer mais
tant au niveau de cholestérol au niveau
2 de tous ceux on accorde une valeur
probablement parce qu'on pense qu'on
peut changer notre quatrième c'est si on
parle du cholestérol pitt et c'est sûr
que n'importe quel cliniciens vous le
dire la sécession qu'on se fie pas aux
jeux sur l'imc pour évaluer l'état de sa
régulation on veut on va passer un bilan
les pizzas et quand vous regardez votre
votre glycémie on va regarder tout un
panel biochimiques le tchèque en fait
votre votre votre examen annuel qui
tissent si vous avez des problèmes de
cholestérol par exemple l on peut vous
prescrire des médicaments pour ben c'est
votre cholestérol bibens on sait que si
on baisse le cholestérol dont on voit on
va changer la trajectoire le du risque
dont on voit on voit diminuer le risque
de développer par exemple des maladies
cardiovasculaires on garde une repos à
zéro le médecin on va en vaut quand même
diminué note risque moi ce que je pense
qu'on devrait faire passer de s'informer
un peu plus sur les habitudes de vie des
gens this way a pas de guidelines
officielle qui disent que le bâti pour
les gens pour évaluer leur état de santé
il faudrait par exemple
mesurer la qualité de leur alimentation
ou leur condition physique tu es à ce
que ces gens là sont actives c'est quoi
leur leurs conditions
cardio-respiratoire le team au jeu je le
dis souvent l'hôte ici j'avais un
marqueur lucky qui pourrait prédire
votre vote risque de
la mortalité cardiovasculaire ou même de
mortalité de toute cause dix ans ce
serait polygame c'est ce serait pas le
cholestérol ce serait pas de la tension
artérielle
ça serait vraiment la condition
cardio-respiratoire lothion honte mais
sur un tapis on te fait un protocole
pour monter des fréquences cardiaques
vraiment élevé on mesure les échanges
gazeux pour aller chercher la quantité
maximale d'oxygène que tu es capable de
tolérer donc ça s'appelle le vo2 max le
ph on a sûrement fait des tests comme ça
mais seul le vo2 max est vraiment un
débat je dirais même le meilleur
prédicteur de
mortalité quand voir là bas bien plus
que toutes les autres facteurs qu'on
qu'on ne compte par les pays-bas ce jeu
personne mesures sont en pratique
limoilou malheureusement répit cccc
clairement démontré que chez les
individus qui ont un verrou 2 max qui
est élevé par exemple comme dans le dans
le 80e perçante il de la population donc
les 20 % des gens qui ont enlevé aux 2
max élevé le sauté peu importe le poulpe
fait peu importe allez les facteurs de
risque si c'est vraiment puissante
indicateurs de mortalité le soupçon le
vo2 max j'imagine qu'ils
qui ont une bonne corrélation avec le
niveau d'activité physique pratiquée par
les personnes se soient qu'une grosse
composante génétique aussi vo2max il ya
des gens qui vont les choses le max est
plus élevé c'est très fluide et je suis
d'accord et athlètes prologue qui font
des fonds d entraînement qui n'ont pas
de bons simple qui ont les pulsations à
130 puis mot juste à côté pour faire le
même genre d'effort à 180 ouais c'est ça
qu'il faut que tu sois capable de monter
des fréquences cardiaques aussi aux
prothèses pas tout le monde qui est
capable par sedan hockey et il ya eu une
grosse
composante génétique ta biologique aussi
le pass poteau monde qui répond de la
même façon c'est est-ce le métier
j'osais les athlètes de haut niveau
comment ils vont quand même se retrouver
sur
certains il le fait que oui à des
petites différences le haut niveau au
niveau du pays que tu perds que tu peux
aller chercher un film aussi ce que je
repense à ses étudiants je me disais
c'est peut-être pas nécessairement de
cibler le fait dans le xxème perçante il
met peut-être de pau à être dans le
xxème perçante ils peuvent aussi perdre
et c'est là que les plus gros gains sont
au fait de ses passes et une condition
physique qui est pas super bonne à une
condition physique qui est moyennement
voire faire beaucoup plus de ça aura un
impact beaucoup plus important sur une
la santé de la population que si par
exemple on passait du 60e ou 85 cents
donc
voilà pour pour l'activité physique
ouais mais j'imagine que tu es dans des
dents des études comme tu parlais tout à
l'heure des études sur le long terme sur
le 10 15 juin et en os conçu des gens
certes est extrêmement difficile
d'isoler un facteur président comprendre
pour essayer de comprendre ses seuls est
le facteur qui vient jouer avec
l'espérance de vie puis avec la
longévité le tir passe qui doit avoir
tellement de facteurs autres que les
métaux de l'activité physique la
nutrition est le poids toutes ces choses
et doit avoir un million la force iran
sont quasiment impossibles
ouais ben c'est soit on s'intéresse
beaucoup d'encore deux demis recherche
lui a trouvé me dont l'algorithme
parfait pour la prédiction du risque de
maladies cardiovasculaires puis
finalement on essaie de développer une
sorte de modèle pour améliorer la
prédiction on va évidemment mesurer les
facteurs de risques on a mentionné
tantôt qui c'est difficile d'avoir des
études dans lesquels on mesurer aux
promotions pour aider questionnaire sur
l'alimentation ou même les niveaux
d'activité physique très vous avez un
emploi qui
qui est manuel est ce que vous faites
d'activité physique récréatif c'est quoi
les sports que vous faites est ce que
vous marchez pour vous pourrez aller
travailler et c'est donc ça c'est
difficile de trouver des corps qui ont
mesuré l'ensemble de ces de ces
paramètres puis aussi la génétique aussi
parce que tire quand quand on parle de
maladie cardiovasculaire bayonne
évidemment aussi une grosse composante
génétique semaine je pense que c'est
important d'en parler
pis
pour les maladies cardiovasculaires les
yeux des cio 10 des centaines
parfaitement des milliers d'endroits
dans notre génome qu'ils ont des
variants génétiques influencent
l'expression nos jeunes puis qui vont
nous nous mettre à risque de développer
des maladies cardiovasculaires le donc
je pense par exemple à des maladies
génétiques comme l'hypercholestérolémie
familiale entre autres qui s'était
saucisses et des enfants qui ont un
cholestérol
qui est dans le 99e perse antique la
distribution de la population puis ces
enfants ne sont pas traités ils peuvent
faire des infarctus avalanche de
chiffres une question des petites de
vitrines cassées génétique c'est sûr pas
du tout mais ce que quelqu'un car c'est
souvent dans ces situations le extrême
c'est évidemment seulement la génétique
mais quand on regarde au niveau
populationnelle ce conte ce qu'on
remarque c'est que les gens qui sont
plus à risque de faire des infarctus et
des gens qui ont des facteurs de risque
mais qui ont aussi une prédisposition
génétique nous est donc monsieur je
pense que le fait de faire du sport le
fait d'avoir une alimentation et qui se
rapproche des dégâts et de langue par
exemple du guide alimentaire canadien
d'avoir une bonne qualité nutritionnelle
on peut faire beaucoup pour la
prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires ce soir est certain
mais c'est sûr qu'une composante
génétique aussi qui fait en sorte que
ben même si même si on fait tout ce
qu'il faut mais on veut on peut quand
même avoir des maladies
cardiovasculaires je pense que c'est un
message qui est important de communiquer
pochette pour lima cardiovasculaires
mais pour d'autres maladies chroniques
comme par exemple le diabète de type 2
c'est des gens qui font qu'ils se font
faire des diagnostics pie ou qui vont
carrément avoir un infarctus pays qui
vont qui vont avoir cédé des grosses
conséquences psychologiques
après avoir développé des maladies comme
ça parce que tu es et regarde regarde
les journaux puisqu'on dit ok bateau de
ces maladies la cdu aux habitudes de vie
pas si tu as eu des maladies sa cause de
tes habitudes de vie il y en a qui vont
regarder 6,20 voyons lancé c'est ma
faute si j'ai su j'ai fait un infarctus
une marque forte jeu développer le
diabète de type 2 pourtant jugée cette
photo comme ce monde si ça marche pour
ceux qui mènent des gens qui font tout
tout croche lui pillon ayant juste une
génétique qui les prédisposent pas ces
maladies le
permettent les autres
j'ai pris l'habitude de veepee j'ai un
projet un poids santé développé de
maladie depuis mais finalement ils y ont
tiré le bon jeu de cartes très gêné
c'est le monde le camp des habitudes de
vie misérables mais qui ont l'air de
s'entraîner cette fois par semaine c'est
sa bévue le pis le poids aussi c'est là
c'est la même chose le tuyau d il ya la
génétique je pense qu'on sous estime
beaucoup
l'importance de la génétique dans la
régulation du poids corporel option
parce que justement et puis ce jour ce
que je viens de dire le s'est basé sur
des sondés il
y avait eu un
un sondage que j'ai regardé qui est
dedans il y avait fondé de la population
américaine puis les gens étaient
capables d'identifier c'est quoi les
lille devaient rentrer humains quittent
qui avait une composante génétique et
comme par exemple si on leur a posé la
question bâti est ce que la couleur des
yeux c'est génétique ballon et whip y
était capable de le d'antillais ce que
les les opinions politiques par exemple
une composante génétique banon absolue
gens étaient capables de
l'identifier correctement pis il faisait
comme une courbe le temps que claquent
la composante génétique
perçu par le public versus la composante
réel qui le moins qui s'éloignait le
plus de la courbe stay l'obésité comme
un parti
ils pensent que le pouvoir c'est réglé
seulement par par notre volonté et notre
nutrition pineau nos habitudes
d'activité physique alors que là il ya
des grosses composants gêné ces copeaux
puis l'auto si ce qui est intéressant ce
lucky que les gens pensaient qu'il y
avait une composante génétique mais qui
ne l'avait pas le sarment c'est
l'orientation sexuelle ou sauverait fait
que avec ce petit joseph la génétique du
poids sont on connait le on connaît les
études depuis tu es là à la fin des
années 80 90 il y avait eu des super
belles études qui ont été faites par un
chercheur américain qui s'appelle mais
kyste aux cordes lui ce qui avait fait
un chercheur américain il y avait un
voyage et au danemark parce que la bo
lyon lyon des bases de données
populationnelle vraiment intéressant je
te poser plusieurs questions c 'est les
années 80 on n'avait pas tout les outils
génétiques de séquençage du génome comme
qu on aujourd'hui que nous on fait
préfère mesurer l'enjeu
c'est de plus en plus accessible au
grand public
allez voir vraiment d'aller check et on
a dit oui exactement donc donc puisque
avait fait c'est qui s'était posé la
question si on réunissait des jumeaux
civile dans dans les études génétiques
souvent on veut étudier des jumeaux
parce qu'ils partagent le même gène
ombles donc lyon les mêmes variations
génétiques les modelages les jolies
jumeaux monozygotes puis ben y avait
regardé des jumeaux qu'ils avaient été
séparés à la naissance donc il y avait
qui avaient vécu dans des familles
qu'ils étaient complètement différent
puis été cas de trou une corrélation
presque parfaite avec le poids des
jumeaux donc si le genou ont pesé 150
livres le jumeau 2 peser entre 145 159
vagues et de l'environnement comme le
mode faire exactement il y aurait même
fait des études chez les enfants adoptés
aussi donc il y avait pris le pot des
parent ni et des enfants adoptés donc
les parents biologiques
puis les parents adoptifs pis
il y avait fait la démonstration que ben
il n'y a aucune corrélation entre le pot
des enfants et leurs parents adoptifs
mais que la corrélation est super bonne
entre le poids des enfants et le moenner
parents biologiques
beck c'est comme de dire que lee le pot
et réguler davantage par les gentils de
transmettre l'argent plutôt que les gens
quittent élèves qui te nourrit ce à tout
les jours c'est vraiment son os et ce
comme je le dis depuis les années 80
c'était moi je parle c'est en tout cas
on pouvait faire des tests des tests
génétiques je les ai fait c'était cela
c'est vraiment drôle si je faisais j'ai
fait ça y'a pas être une dizaine
d'années par bong autonome et la
compagnie le partout et nitry ennemi
tout ça a commencé au début puis c'est
moche mais je m'intéresse à la génétique
des maladies cardiométaboliques
avec le dit assez c'est vraiment le fun
si je vois renvoyer un échantillon de
salive qui vont même à donner tout mon
génomes qui sait ça va être vraiment que
ça va vraiment une expérience positive
en place aux autres e-coli chaussures
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui peuvent trouver des nouveaux gènes
de susceptibilité aux maladies puissent
fait que j'ai finalement après ce qu'on
a su ce qu'ils vendaient comme toutes
nos informations indiquent pour
garder
mais tu peux regarder plusieurs rapports
puis mouiller ma vie il m'avait dit ben
on a regardé jambon je sais plus combien
au regard des 400 variations dans son
génome qui avec ton âge son sexe
mais on est capable de dire que tu es un
indice de masse corporelle de 28 puis
bam ont existé masse corporelle c'est
pas mal vêtues fait exprès petit mozart
en fait ça a été une des façons pour moi
devait embarquer que tu sais si le poids
que j'ai je sais que
le poids que j y vois toujours à 4%
supérieure à la moyenne populationnelle
le fait que ces com - moment pour
naturel le fait que tu es si si je pars
du pro ben mon poing un vous revenez
rast poste points elo pittis sigean gang
basse et vaud il va peut-être venir
naturellement à la distribution
populationnelle le fait qu'il ait
l'effet que la génétique c'est vraiment
un facteur important pour la simulation
du si ce qui expliquerait j'imagine
pourquoi tu quand on parle de culture de
dieppe qu'on parle que tout le temps
même si les gens font diète piquionne
perte de poids attribués à des
changements drastiques d'habitudes de
vie ça tient jamais parce qu'au final tu
revient essentiellement aux poules côté
programmé dans le fond si ce que
j'entends exactement donc c'est vraiment
bien démontré tri
aujourd'hui présentement elle les
l'évolution de l'espèce humaine au fait
en sorte qu' on est résistant aux audi
est le ya eu des risées en est
d'ailleurs prouve c'est fou parce que
qu'ils continuent ce que
je souhaite que cet arbre mais on ya des
dizaines de mécanismes biologiques qui
font en sorte que c'est à peu près
impossible de perdre du poids au pirée
comme je le disais tantôt baisse il ya
plusieurs facteurs génétiques il ya plus
que mille région dans notre génome qui
vont influencer notre poule puis ben
nous on a des travaux en cours là dessus
qu'ils démontrent que ben parmi ces
mails région le y en a au moins soixante
dix qui sont associés à des protéines
qui sont dans le cerveau donc la plupart
des variations dans notre génome humain
sont exprimés dans le cerveau puis ça ça
va réguler réguler la prise alimentaire
ça va réguler la relation qu'on a avec
la avec notre alimentation
la régulation de nos émotions la prise
de décision et cetera pis si c'est un
peu normal le parsien l'être humain a
toujours évolué à part dans les 40
dernières années dans un environnement
que la nourriture était pas toujours
présentes
fréquenta ville l'occasion de manger ben
il fallait que tu manges s'est peu à peu
près par ses
fils avait posté qu'un la prochaine fois
que tu es allé manger hulotistes par
exemple si tu prends un gros lot les
midis bat et on le cerveau il sait pas
que le frij l'oeil et plein chez vous
puis quentinois fait comprendre
exactement par
des mécanismes d'appétit qui vont se
mettre en place trois quatre heures plus
tard puis tu votes tu veux manger autant
quand même le nombre de ceux ci une des
composantes
de l'aspect de l'aspect biologique au
sipi c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
aussi surtout chez les femmes c cédille
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'hormones
aussi qui vont qui vont réguler notre
prise alimentaire il y en a une par
exemple dont on on parle pas beaucoup
c'est quand on parle d'ordre en eau par
les hormones thyroïdiennes de l'insuline
ces choses là mais une hormone qui est
sécrétée par notre tissu adipeux donc
par nos cellules graisseuses qui
s'appelle la leptine cela leptine ce que
ça va faire c'est que ça va augmenter
après la prise d'un repos ça veut dire à
notre cerveau battu correct le jute on a
on assez mangé pieds tu peux déposer à
cuire après après ton ton assiette de
spaghetti m ces deux gars est plus fin
et le cnt aurait lieu souvent de place
pour le dessert par exemple
exactement
pilat les teams ce que ça va faire aussi
c'est que ça va on peut agir comme un
comme un thermos côté l'élève pour la
régulation de la température chez vous
mme anne cécile la température basse
trop bas le thermostat va embarquer et
puis le chauffage vous avoir embarqué
bastien peut sauter comme si tu te fais
dédiée ati prive de nourriture belle à
la leptine avoir bcp soit ton cerveau il
ya me repos mais bien sûr puisse s'y
abaisse beaucoup trop la leptine c'est
comme si tu envoyé un message à ton à
ton cerveau que le têt en situation de
stress est en situation de famine ce
savoir et fluence est aussi beaucoup la
reproduction chez les femmes comme par
exemple qui font des diètes c'est sévère
un point qui vont développer des
problèmes d'anorexie par exemple c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles les
menstruations vont mal il dit parce que
ce que ton cerveau comprends c'est
qu'ils étaient dans une situation
tellement difficile sur le plan de
l'accès à l'alimentation de l'accès aux
calorique mal-être pas l'énergie pour
pour avoir une grossesse qui va durer
neuf mois au pis puis elle était ton
enfant non pour ce quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude va baisser ben les
menstruations vont arrêter parce que dix
balles à qui on est en situation de
famine le fait que perfect pour ce que
dans le fond sion c'est important puis
on a des mécanismes de régulation
vraiment bien huilé glamour pour
résister aux diacres le texte pour ce
que les gens bâti jeu là on le suit le
maintenant la plupart des gens qui vont
diminue leur alimentation leur apport
calorique bêtes ils vont perdre un peu
de poids au début cela qu'ils sont
capables d'en perdre passait vraiment
pas tout le monde puis ben pour ce
qu'ils sont capables d'en perdre l on va
voir sous après trois mois après six
mois d x prend une belle peau
naturellement comme on parle tant qu il
va revenir il va revenir à ce qui était
au départ puis mettons comprends la
question la plus simple mais en même
temps j'ai l'impression que la réponse
doit être extrêmement complexe si j'ai
un genre moins de calories que gens
dépensent dans une journée qu'est ce qui
se passe parce que tu es on voit souvent
les lions mesure que dans cette espèce
de culture de diète lendemain sort
perdre du poids souvent on voit cette
équation là que m'étant simplifié au
plus beau possible pour perdre du poids
faut que tu un jour en moins de calories
et en dépenses qu'en est il
c'est vrai le trait que ce serait une
des premières lois de la thermodynamique
le théier ne se perd rien ne se
fait si tu es capable de
maintenir un déficit calorique à long
terme la plupart des gens va perdre
seront perdus pour ben bon tempo la
plupart pas c'est difficile de pas jouer
s'il n'y a pas vraiment d études qui ont
été faites là dessus donc des gens qui
vont perdre du poids il ya des gens qui
en perdrons pas notamment puissant
encore une fois il ya une grosse
composante génétique à savoir dans une
situation de restriction calorique
qui va perdre du pot pikine en perdre au
pilote cg des travaux en tête devant
cherchant même de l'université laval qui
s'appelle claude bouchard qui a fait de
ce qui en fait c'est qu'ils ont pris des
jumeaux puis ils ont promis sur une
restriction calorique mais ils ont mis
dans un dans un excès de kahler qui donc
des jumeaux mâles font de la restriction
mais quand il faut choisir bourses
d'études hall c40 plus de pile ou face
marin qui va d'un excellent restrictions
mais finalement c'est en france qu'on
pense que c'est facile de détente en
surplus énergétique mais c'est plus de
challenger qu'on pense justement l'usc
avait fait ce qu'ils avaient pris des
badges cgt pôle celui de cet automne
équipe à lui merci laval qui avait mis
des jumeaux en surplus calorique pendant
100 jours puis donc donc là c'est ce
qu'ils font avec ce type d'étude le sait
que bin tantôt je vous disais que les
jeunes de l'obésité souvent ils étaient
extraits dans le cerveau mais le sait
que c'est que la sauce influence notre
prise alimentaire mais dans cette
attitude yeux c'est comme si on avait
tort c'est le cerveau parce qu on
nourrissait on oursel et les gens
vivront leur dise aujourd'hui ben toi
par rapport à
att était besoin énergétique il faut tu
manges pour dire quelque chose 3000 cas
là on va te donner 3000 kcal aujourd'hui
fixées par son cerveau qui décide du
nombre de calories le masseur évidemment
la plupart des des jumeaux parce qu'ils
étaient justement en surplus énergétique
ben il la plupart au prix du pot mais
encore une fois il y en a qui ont pris
deux kilos il y en a qui ont pris dix
kilos d'ici le 1er jumeaux avaient pris
deux kilos l'otan avait pris 2,10 dans
un autre site de jumeaux il y en aurait
pris 10 kilos l'otan avait pris 10 aussi
même si ça a été fait aussi au niveau de
la restriction calorique donc au lieu de
voir un surplus énergétiques ont fait de
restrictions caloriques corrélation
parfaite avec une restriction calorique
autant fait par l'alimentation que par
l'activité physique mathieu on peut on
peut jouer sur la balance énergétique en
diminuant la port mais aussi en en
augmentant la dépense énergétique dans
les deux cas les résultats étaient était
sans équivoque dans le sens qu on
perdait du poids quand on était en
balance énergétique négative mais il y
avait une variabilité interindividuelle
qui était vraiment impressionnante on
interrompt le podcast pour vous parler
encore une fois d'options action
ça sert d'être ennemis qu'on fait tout
simplement la compagnie avec jardin
falsetto un policier
auxilio 2 nous en a parlé un petit peu
au début du podcast mais ils ont une
politique de transparence des prix si
vous allez voir sur votre site sur leur
site web en fait et que vous regardez
votre forfait internet vous allez voir
exactement chaque dollar vaut ou de
capote surprise y ait pas de frais
cachés n'y a pas de variabilité puis
ainsi vous avez même des questions par
rapport à leurs services dont il
conservait sa clientèle incroyable quand
apple le sait comme chat même avec la
petite chatte 4 n'importe quoi
son le sont présents sont forcés comme
appli
damas a appelé quelqu'un tu es qui vont
rassurer que fera sentir bien chez oxz
où c'est exactement ce qu'ils ont
vraiment laissé sa clientèle à coeur ils
leur plateforme est facile tout va bien
c'est pas compliqué c'est c'est vraiment
la bomba d'affaires de 3 mots de passe
pour rentrer dans mon espace du monde
aussi aux affaires complexes que vous
perdez tout le talent est une daube ces
affaires le super simple utiliser le
code promo sans filtre en un mot pour un
mot gratuit comme on dit tantôt si vous
aimez pas se
retourner lorsque vous étiez merci optio
oxoby j'ai l'impression que le problème
est que cette disette lui justement de
restriction calorique c'est que n'est
pas soutenable dans ce sens qu'ils
resteront à l'arrêt que c'est une vie
avoir finalement un clip ça va engendrer
sur d'autres problèmes comme 10 des
rages et quand vous passez un mcdo sur
la remise pour bodmer est arrêté puis
finalement ça ne vous sera pas maintenir
sur le long terme non mais c'est surtout
josé luis la culture didier tu es
tellement
implanté dans notre cerveau mindtree dès
l'enfance le les personnes grosses seuls
font dire par leur parrain par leur
famille proche par leurs amis à l'école
vont subir de de l'intimidation
ils vont ils vont évidemment à voir j'ai
tendance à ce blanc me permettre ce soir
forte mais c'est sur le fait c'est
qu'ils manquent de volonté hippiques
sont que sont paresseux pics sont pas
capables de se contrôler alors qu'ils y
c'est comme comme joli stand et put en
tout c'est génétique pythie le note
notre manque de volonté en rien à voir
avec avec le poids contenu puis ça ça va
ça va devenir extrêmement ch'ti m pour
pour les personnes de dada de vivre ce
regard de la société qui leur dit que
ben leur corps y est pas conforme aux
standards de de beauté à l'acceptation
au standard corporels que ben justement
l'industrie l'industrie des régimes
l'industrie des diètes
l'industrie de la publicité du marketing
qui leur peau est essentiellement vous
le dire que vous devriez être
insatisfait de votre propre pays bas
pour pour devenir satisfait de votre
poubelle il faut changer votre corps
même si votre corps est parfaitement
valide
que dans le fond puis évidemment on va
voir des produits pour ce pitre y
acheter le puits consommer notre produit
puis vous allez vite et d'endemol la
société et puis vous allez vous vous
conformez c'est ce qu'il est et lili
jeunes veulent ou système où je le voi
ggg jeune fille qui est en maternelle
devant mario qui est on ne peut plus
jeunes puis je je le vois le lan leur
désir de se conformer de dette entend
dans la moyenne de la validation par les
pairs à quel point c'est tellement
important benz imaginer parce que dans
le fond te tirer comme le mauvais jeu de
cartes à l'autriche élite cpie évident
on peut entrer dans toutes sortes
d'enjeux sociaux économiques des enjeux
de
de climat familial et ses rangs et
bah ça peut devenir ça peut devenir
vraiment dommageable à long terme chez
ces gens là qui vivent dans cette
culture là pendant tes dépenses dit
pendant des années que souvent c'est
toute une vie à avoir un estime de soi
qui qui est qui vraiment mise à mal par
par la société dans laquelle on vit par
le regard que les autres ont sur nous
une personne qui
met tant qu'une alimentation qui est qui
qui est pas optimal de ton petit kiki
sédentaires ski et mettons de changer
ses études de ville a commencé à bouger
quand ça mieux manger plus de fruits et
légumes est heureux est ce que ces
changements louve en résulte est souvent
une paire de poupées nécessairement
peut-être peut-être que oui peut-être
que non t on le sait pas si c'est mieux
que ce que je que j'entends souvent tic
comme par exemple quand les gens vont
consulter leur médecin par exemple et
ils sont sont en situation de surpoids
ou d'obésité
puis ben ils vont voir un médecin pour
consulter pour n'importe qui n'importe
quoi un problème de genou et diminuerait
nouveautés peu importe la première chose
qu'ils vont se faire dire on se sépare
du pot
ok perdu pour oui mais tu es comment
comment on perd
on contrôle passe à neutre pour le dis
moi j'aimerais bien sûr
ghania le tri le ti jean marc chemin
boisé que je vois que je vois gagner le
tri le tc comme ce peut être ce prêt
dans le trouble sur la santé financière
bel exemple d'argent
effective tu peux faire des tu veux pas
des choses pour essayer de gagner plus
d'argent mais sa base et 4e plus riches
peut-être se fait des efforts tu vas pas
te va peut-être réussir mais c'est la
même chose comme par exemple pour la
perte de poids le tri ce que ce conte ce
convoi ziro jambes et si c'est justement
comme celle du dôme c'est améliorer vos
habitudes de vie et manger manger plus
de fruits plus de légumes payés plus de
protéines d'origine végétale assez
d'augmenter votre consommation de grains
entiers début vais pas trop de liqueur
but de loi placette cette erreur et pee
wee sait si vous êtes sédentaires et
essayer de trouver dans votre quotidien
comment vous pourriez augmenter votre
oeuvre votre votre niveau d'activité
physique c'est trouver l'activité
physique qui vous convient est ce que ça
prenne part des déplacements actifs à ce
que ça peut être un jouet lançant dans
une ligue de garage au hockey est ce que
c'est en faisant de la danse et peu
importe en ce que ça va être bâton pour
les personnes plus au rejet en faisant
plus de jardinage et c'est reparti moi
je rends pour sur le tir et puis je veux
c'est démontrer scientifiquement que peu
importe le plus c'est le fait de faire
ces changements le mais savoir un
incident ce vraiment positive sur le
risque de le diabète de type 2 maladies
cardiovasculaires etc mais ça veut pas
dire que ces gens enlevons perdu pour
nécessairement y en a qui ont perdu bout
mais pense que la plupart des gens en
perdre repos mais ce qu'on se cacher par
exemple c'est que tout le monde ou
améliorer sa santé le fait que l'on sait
que quand on parle du traitement de
l'obésité par exemple moi je vois
essentiellement deux options le cc soit
la voie des des régimes amaigrissants
pis la restriction calorique à l'extrême
qui va faire perdre du pot à certaines
personnes mais surtout sa perte de poids
à long terme qui m'aiment justement
quand tu fais ce bain souvent tu vas
reprendre le pot puis c'est ton cerveau
il va s'en rappeler de celui monza et le
j'ai pas aimé ce que j'ai vécu le fait
qu'elle va augmenter mon 7 points que le
pigeon je veux m'assurer que je veux je
dois maintenir mon lait pro kg le joueur
monte je vois le monté d'une coche enfin
que si tu fais toujours ces cycles de
perte de poids de regard pour sa belle
idylle millions mais à la fin de la
journée ou à fin de l'année bâton
pourrait être plus élevé que qu'est-ce
qui était qu'est ce qui était au départ
puis ça commence à vraiment pas d'effet
sur la santé ciss a des effets sur la
santé oms avait des effets néfastes des
effets vraiment toxique sur ton estime
de soi sur la santé mentale la relation
qui est avec ton corps ou avec la
nourriture fait qu'il ya comme je veux
juste des mauvais côtés mois ce qui
donne mais d'un autre côté tu peux dire
comme je dis ben c'est à dire à gérer le
sait exactement il ya un hic vont perdre
du poids il y en ait qui perdront pas de
points mais on le sait que tout le monde
a faim de la journée vont améliorer sa
santé est ce pour ça qu'il faut d'abord
jouer sur ce message le mais aussi
changer les normes sociales le thé pour
dire ben là c'est le poids c'est ici
c'est une variable parmi tant d'autres
qui va définir des définir une personne
puis ces pauvres parce qu'une personne
un poids élevé grâce une mauvaise
personne ou qui est paresseuse ou un
manque de volonté c'est un attribut
cette personne là
c'est pas à ces personnes là de se
modifier leur corps pour adhérer aux
normes sociales c'est au norme sociale a
évolué pour être sûr qu'on peut créer un
environnement qui est inclusive pour
pour toutes les personnes peu importe là
sachant que justement c'est le common
explique débutantes ou que le pot est
majoritairement influencé par la
génétique finalement mais aussi tu
aimais les problèmes cardiovasculaires
et rita dessus mais ça peut être dans un
sens
rassurant de savoir que mon corps est
juste comme ceux qui jugent pas parce
que je suis parent est sûr parce que je
pas bon c'est juste pis si c'est juste
comme ça mais inversement si quelqu'un
qui
qui souffrent de maladies
cardiovasculaires qui sont héréditaires
est-ce que je jouais mal a dû quand même
des choses que je peux faire pour
pour essayer de renverser ce même si
j'ai une prédisposition génétique qui
portera maintenant ça c'est une super
bonne question au pays effectivement si
on a fait beaucoup de progrès sur la
prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires dans l'envié dans les
soixante dix dernières années le tir
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
les hommes le pit et regardez les la
mortalité des de vos grands parents par
exemple souvent dans dans notre famille
on auto en auto sans un grand père ou un
grand tong qui est mort d'une crise du
quart à 55,1 piller this c'était
vraiment un fléau au site à cette époque
lui puis on a fait des progrès
spectaculaires sur l'air sur la
prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires
que ce soit avec des médicaments avec
des nouvelles techniques chirurgicales
puis en prévention de certains facteurs
de risque le donc souvent tes évidemment
quand il fallait face à 55 ans mais
c'est parce qu'il n'y ait une bonne
composantes génie de ces cas c'est pas
tout le monde peut aider par tous non
plus payé bien effectivement joseph il
ya plusieurs façons qui sont supportés
par la science de diminuer son risque
même si on a une histoire familiale même
si on a un profil génétique qui
peut-être pas optimale parce que
justement on a tiré le mauvais jeu de
cartes à l'autriche génétiques des
maladies cardiovasculaires ben le fait
de bien manger le fait de bouger le fait
de prendre ses médicaments aussi
c'est des pilules contre le cholestérol
contre l'hypertension peut même si
souvent on va dire des prendre ou de
prescrire à des gens qui ont déjà fait
un infarctus mais le peut-être que dans
ces situations le on pourrait donner des
mythes des médicaments à titre préventif
parce que justement il ya un lien il ya
une histoire familiale le fait qu très
souvent aussi quand j'entends ce que
c'est l'image du cardio vasculaires
c'est essentiellement juste dû aux
habitudes de vie ben c'est basé sur une
science qui qui est très qui est pas
très solides sont le textile étude
observationnelle tepa garde non
seulement d'établir un lien de cause à
effet entre tous puis ben c'est juste un
mot ce que j c chez ces gens là bas
c'est
prenant des médicaments le savent
vraiment orienté le diminue la
trajectoire du du risque pizza va
diminuer votre risque loti jeu j'ai vu
récemment que j'avais un jardin
cholestérol qui est qu'ils étaient il
veut il le tue moi je je je fais mes
choix mais 150 minutes d'activité
physique par semaine c'est joseph je
mange quand même bien il le tire une
alimentation presque presque entièrement
végétale mélange de mon médecin m'a dit
ben le téton temps cholestérol est élevé
j'ai aussi bon je regardais aussi mais
facteurs génétiques qui était peut-être
pas décemment
le teaser ya tellement de tellement des
informations si là dessus le c'est
complètement foule sur le cholestérol
puis la santé le
regarde les lily les ans que je les
encourage pas les gens de force le
médecin mais c'est quoi ce qu'on attend
principalement comme des informations
elle sait ce que c'est qu'elle est les
pilules contre le cholestérol par
exemple si inutile que fit une efficace
que trop de gens qui en prennent pour
rien qu'il est finalement que le
cholestérol c'est pas vrai que c'est un
facteur de risque des maladies
cardiovasculaires cc c'est pas mal là la
main mais rhétorique que les quais les
théories conspirationnistes sur la copie
donc je suis content dans ce parce que
pendant ce temps le géant j'entends
pulite irruption blues connaissent
terres sont occupées sur l'exacte e
mandat c'est ça fait que fait josé
really les lisent les cheveux parce que
je suis il ya des études assez assez
bien fait ce qui démontre bien
finalement c'est les effets secondaires
qu'on parle de ses médicaments le dessus
sont pas aussi importants que ces pièces
et des médicaments etc sans que son
générique qui cote argué que ce soit
moins qu'en juin quand j'ai vu que
j'avais un profil des gosses qui kim
était peut-être les jeunes dont je pense
que je le dirige parfaitement le jeu pas
de mauvaises personnes montent à prendre
sa santé en main est important c'est un
vin il est souvent trop tard pour
décider de prendre ça s'entend même ayez
jamais trop tôt c'est un peu comme
investir dans un reér le thé plus tu es
jeune tu t'investis bâti plus tu vas
avoir des bénéfices qui sont à long
terme alors que s'ils commencent à
cotiser à son reer à 58 ans bains et le
verrou de bénéfices
ça fait deux fois que tu mentionnes puis
pis si on en a parlé aussi souvent au
studio sfr sans fil paquet de la
l'alimentation végétale pour la santé
cardiovasculaire puis
moi je suis weygand
personnellement puis dans ma transition
on a abordé les arguments éthiques les
arguments environnementaux qui était
hors de tout doute puis desquels on ont
posé plus de questions par contre des
arguments la santé oms était challenge
est souvent tient
beaucoup de monde qui prouve que la
viande rouge est mal pour vous sauf que
ce ça a été remis en question par des
études par des parts d notamment
les concessions qu'on avait avec olivier
bernard dans le pharmacien qui dit que
c'était pas si clair que ceux qui
avaient un lien
que tu dis promeneurs alimentation
végétale est ce que la viande au des
liens de causalité avec les maladies
cardiovasculaires ou la santé
cardiovasculaire qu'est ce que la
science nous dit là dessus bon je crois
pas que se pose la question j'ai vu
quand même un jour l'homme en plus il
est à
montréal un des bons exactement fait que
non
effectivement comme je te dis bah tu
sais toi tu es vegan mots j'ai asseyé de
leitza durée j'adorais 48 ans avec avec
deux petites filles qui veulent du
véhicule c'est plus facile
mécanique huit bateaux et c'est plus de
jeu l'excellent expérimente des fois de
voir pékin de le faire non et puis autre
avantage sur le bacon au site et le
bacon vegan moi j'aime bien ça mais le
regard de désespoir que j'ai eu quand
j'ai fait goûter sa missive
elle s attendent au goût du bacon tout
cyktor paul goude bio mais elle s'attend
à cinq ans c'est dire à quel point nos
mécanismes centraux samson et partage
dans notre quête de trouver quelque
chose qui grâce à lee satisfaisant le
quatre sans garde des enfants le sait
beaucoup de réponses à des questions car
il faut revenir à ta question ben moi je
pense que
c'est on peut se poser des questions ce
qu est l aliment est meilleur que la
haute est bon 6e je pense que ce qui est
important c'est de regarder l'ensemble
de l'alimentation la qualité de notre
alimentation parce que tu peux avoir une
alimentation vegan qui
lâche un exact je faisais une piscine
vegan avec un coq
s'améliorer à chaque fois que tu est en
route pour avoir exactement
c'est la même chose au niveau des diètes
carnivores bêtise je dirais tu peux tu
peux manger temps une espèce de petite
attaques qui de boeuf avec
c'est à purée d'avocat avec la salade
niçoise à côté un petit verre de vin ce
sera pas ce sera pas nécessairement
dommageable pour pour ta santé on sent
là dessus mais à alimentation égal parce
que je suis tout le temps sur la
question tué parce qu'évidemment
quelqu'un qui maximise son alimentation
pratiquement peu importe ton type
d'alimentation ça va être positif mais
alimentation égalé ce qui est des
différentes baj c'est difficile parce
que toyota il n'ya pas d'étude prenez
randomisée contrôlée là dessus d'un
effet qu'à partir de là on peut juste
spéculer essentiellement le métier une
des raisons pour laquelle les lignes
directrices pitt et santé canada puis
bon les marqueurs avec l'associé chaînes
aux états unis vont ils vont ils vont
suggère aux gens de se tourner vers une
alimentation végétale bah c'est aussi
pour diminuer les gras saturés le petit
joseph soit aussi je comprends que
comprend que s'est débattu le mais je
pense que le yoga même un consensus qui
qui qui dit que tu es moins tu consommes
de gras saturés le telegraph saturé on
va retrouver ce dans les produits
laitiers dans les produits de viande
rouge et ses robes etc je pense que je
pense que tu as senti vaut
mieux
mais effectivement tout ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte de qualité
nutritionnelle eczéma quand je regarde
les études d'instruction qui dit abel
est arrêté de manger tel aliment parce
que c'est sa cause le cancer peu
ballottée premiers pas d'études
randomisées qui ont été faits de là
dessus le pi ben cats mais a ajusté pour
d'autres facteurs qui sont corrélés avec
la consommation de cet aliment le bâti
faut faire attention le fait que c'est
oui il faut comprendre le 6 du lot mais
moi je pense que le message que ces
études leur envoie c'est que
suit les recommandations du guide
alimentaire canadien à des travaux en
cours là dessus aussi qui qui tendent à
démontrer que c'est effectivement
bénéfice pour bénéfique pour la santé
puis encore une fois c'est il faut pas
viser la perfection dans notre
alimentation déjà en parlais tantôt au
niveau de l'activité physique quand on
est au 90e perse antique si je vous vois
pas de gros gains à faire que de mon
centième perçante il mais pour les gens
qui ont une qualité elle nutritionnelle
qui pète en bas de l'ami de la moyenne
bâti de faire des efforts pour que c'est
là qu'on va faire des gains je pense en
santé publique l'effectif c'est une
chose qu'on qu'on essaie de qu'on essaie
de passer comme message messi aussi sait
on le voit présentement avec les prix
des aliments qui étendrait sept ans plus
tard un peu au mur du socio-économique
les amants pitié d'acheter des légumes
secs au timbre si ça fait que les gens
qui sont privilégiés vont pouvoir
continuer à
bien s'alimenter parce que batista
occupe une [ __ ] pour un petit
pourcentage de leur budget mendy que ton
alimentation passe de deux chez promodès
eyes à 18% ton budget bâti ça change pas
grand chose mais quand c'est là la
moitié de ton budget qui passe dans
l'alimentation le titre va faire des
choix qui qui seront pas nécessairement
bon pour la santé fait qu'ils sont
fatigués en santé publique moi je pense
qu'il faut vraiment faire en sorte de
qu'il faut démocratiser
l'accès à une alimentation n'est de
bonne qualité pour pour les populations
les plus vulnérables pour les gens qui
vivent par exemple dans dans des déserts
alimentaires on voit ce qu'on voit ça en
région au sol dans l'est dans les grands
centres où c'était autant à montréal
qu'à québec
des fois c'est extrêmement difficile de
trouver un commerce de proximité qui va
offrir des aliments frais et variés un
prix réduit les annales exact en a fait
l'expérience toutefois le tue on sait
pas si le commentaire dans le short
qu'on était misérable comment jouer à
bloc depuis qu on était là on se dit on
a réussi sept 2000 cas ça nous a coûté 5
pia s'est cassé quelques masques rival
variés qui rivalisent avec ceux que ce
prix là attendez qu'elle rit ingéré
verser ce prix
c'est que c'est des aliments qui sont
pas la table quand on aime ça pis bon
sens peut-être pas vraiment super bien
après sur le coup et quand c'est quand
qu'on mange autant de plaisir faux faux
faux aussi considérer cette notion de
plaisir dans dans l'alimentation aussi
puis bah je pense que tu proviens de la
plupart d'entre nous ont des efforts à
faire pour aller chercher un peu plus de
plaisir dans l'une dans une alimentation
un peu plus il faut se forcer à voter il
faut cuisiner va prendre
un
peu de prôner dit que maintenant en
termes de types d'alimentation la diète
méditerranéenne ce serait une bonne
façon de se demander c'est quoi en gros
oui la diète méditerranéenne des bonnes
façons de s'alimenter mais c'est aussi
la seule qui ait un essai clinique
randomisé contrôlé que t'es fait chez
7500 personnes une étude espagnole c'est
l'étude prédit m a été publiée dans le
new england jeune homme et des scènes en
2013 ce séjour
[Rires]
pour les jeunes des codes sont
incertains nation c'est les maths et
papa je savais pas c'est que ma force
depuis tantôt pour paris
est une
des seules études en nutrition le cateau
monde
effectue aussi avait pris c'est qu'ils
avaient pris 7500 espagnol de san suu
kyi a été fait en espagne depuis lors
les avait séparés en trois groupes
dans un groupe qui s'était bâti
continuer le business as usual n'y avait
pas vraiment de restrictions mais
découragé un peu la diète
méditerranéenne et même si c'est pas
nous sommes en éthique de le faire
raison pour laquelle c'est difficile de
faire des essais cliniques randomisés et
audi pour faire des essais cliniques
randomisés sur le tabou sur l'alcool
s'est passé politique du
fait qu'avec lead avec des semences a
jugé hors continuer mais
spi dans l'autre dans les deux autres
bruts traitement ce qui avait fait c'est
que j'avais dit aux gens de manger
davantage mais de méditerranée donc plus
de fruits plus de légumes avec beaucoup
d'huile végétale beaucoup plus de
nouveaux par exemple le ces gens là ils
ont randonné le ses clients mettaient
par toulouse 2-2 l'huile d'olive le
titre a quasiment
traitement litres par jour
il y en a été le para peu près puis
bâtisse et de manger par exemple plus de
poissons au lieu de la viande d'acier
diminuer les sucreries les pâtisseries
des eaux au dessert de tête mais non
consommée un oeil aux gourous lieu d'une
pâtisserie pitié d'augmenter sa quantité
de fruits légumes je suis combien de
temps ça va durer si je me souviens bien
cinq ans fait que chez des gens qui
étaient à haut risque de mettre
cardiovasculaires répression des gens
qui avaient fait un infarctus il y en
avait peut-être qu'il n'avait fait mais
j'ai déjanté qui avait un cholestérol
élevé et tension artérielle dit que tu
voyais que sont les algorithmes de
traitement l'oeil était dans une
désagréable de prédiction pardon était
dans une catégorie aux risques de
maladies cardiovasculaires pis ils ont
regardé devant la différence anti entier
groupe le puits bain une réduction du
risque de d'avoir des abc d'avoir des
infarctus d'à peu près 30 % chez les
gens qui ont qui qui étaient sur les
rangs de miser sur la diète
méditerranéenne texas et c'est super
important comme comme mes études c'est
une des plus grosses qui avait été faite
sur le sujet y avait déjà une étude en
france qui avait été faite sur le sujet
puis
ses effectifs d'enfoncer 30 % fixé c'est
pas ces passants pour ça non plus le
titre en bourse a c'est à peu près le
même le même effet qu'une pilule contre
le cholestérol votre données de ses
échecs ses superbes on s'est basé sur
des sur des données probantes mais c'est
pas non plus la panacée l'effectif qui
combine les deux
soient pas d'être là dessus mais t on
pense que c'est probablement le plus
important qui aussi ce qui est important
de noter aussi ses gants cette étude le
may a pas eu de perte de poids non plus
le dirigeant était sa diète
méditerranéenne il peser le poids des
gens afin de l'étude chez les gens qui
étaient sa diète méditerranéenne chez
les gens qui étaient sur l'ordi est
était exactement pareil donc
c'est fixé l'étude france est exactement
même chose qui est pas encore une étude
qui a démontré que la perte de poids par
la modification des habitudes de vie
s'était associé à des bénéfices sur la
santé cardiovasculaire normalise on dit
aux gens le perdez du poids perdu du
poids ça va diminuer votre risque mais
mais y'a pas encore une étude que des
auteurs qui prouve survie des étudiants
essayaient aussi le de démontrer ce
puits mais finalement c'était pas parce
que ça marche pas nécessairement la
perte de poids mais c'est que la perte
de poids en tant que telle ne fonctionne
pas on n'est pas capable de trouver deux
groupes de rang des besoins groupe sur
une perte de poids puis de l'aube
l'autre groupe sort pas de perte de
poids parce que les gens qui sont rang
des musées dans le groupe perte de
promet sont regardables de perdus pour
même si cela redonne des substituts de
repas histoire dit de bouger
des bénéfices à
avoir une saine alimentation
mais quand tu dis aux jambes elle aussi
se réaliser sur une sur une diète lopy
vraiment l'objectif principal seydou
fois perdu peau ben vu que ça marche pas
on n'est pas capable de faire une étude
dans dans le sens du monde fait il y en
aura probablement jamais d'études les
ventes aux jeux je parlais des 10
pilules contre le cholestérol bt mougel
si je prends deux pilules contre le
cholestérol que vous aussi mais votre
cholestérol va baisser ses prix il faut
baisser et puis cette baisse va se
maintenir sur le long terme fait qu
on est capable de tester notre hypothèse
mais avec la perte de poids n'est même
pas capable de tester l'hypothèse parce
que je t'aime les gens perdus beaux
débuts après c'est le pur roman vim il
va se ramasser les deux groupes seront
seront pas ils vont être comparables sur
la perte de poids ou affecter leurs
risques de développer des maladies à
long terme ben oui il va y vont être
livrés être comparable ou si fait que
c'est pour les mettre du coeur mais pour
le titre quand on pense aux pros puis la
santé souvent la première maladie qu'on
va penser si le diabète de type 2 ainsi
une relation seuil épidémiologique entre
les deux on voit la corrélation on on
observe c'est juste qu'on peut plus me
dire hors de tout doute que c'est la
côte finalement c'est ce web et en fait
c'est plus compliqué que quand je
regarde l'association entre le poids
puis la santé c'est sûr que les gens qui
vont avoir un indice de masse corporelle
qui est plus élevé statistiquement ils
vont plus à risque de développer des
maladies je dire ce
cd montrés globalement il ya des études
qui sont à peu près à tous les jours là
dessus
c'est vraiment facile de faire de faire
la corrélation entre les deux qui
souvent tic un quinqua lige les
chercheurs les chercheurs ont pu des
études comme ceux bâtis ça va se
ramasser des médiums bon débat le lober
stries sa cause
le cancer ce à cause
de tes lakovic et imite bon fait que ça
c'est une chose mais aussi le sous texte
a dit c'est que les gens ont des
habitudes de vie catastrophique effectué
six 6 prennent en main bâti savoir
diminuer les risques de développer ces
maladies le temps pour faire la relation
de cause à effet ben il faut démontrer
que c'est que cette relation là est
indépendant des facteurs confondants
aussi parce que il ya des facteurs qui
influencent le pouillot des facteurs qui
influencent les maladies puis souvent
c'est on connaît pas nécessairement la
chaîne causale dedans dans la culture
dédié à ton ce qu'on dit dans dans les
médias aussi secours deeba c'est les
gens mangent mal les gens bougent pas
donc son gros don qui développent des
maladies métier c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça en réalité parce que ces
études le bas ne sont pas capables de
différencier les personnes grosses des
personnes m'en est ce parce que les
personnes grosses les personnes minces
sont pas juste différente avec en
fonction de leur propre et depuis de
leur attitude de ville jeudi il ya un
paquet tracteur qui vont influencer le
pour puis le risque de maladie puis qui
vont comme un peu un peu brisé cette
cette chaîne causale lentilles des
facteurs biologiques et des facteurs
familiaux environnementaux économiques
politiques ou géographiques
cette erreur des enjeux de statut
socioéconomique des enjeux de racisme
aussi dit qu'il faut en sortir c'est à
peu près impossible d'isoler la
composant pour danser dans ses études le
fait qu'on fait des corrélations mais
c'est pipi effectivement je pense que
comme une partie de l'effet qui est
causé par par le la grèce puisse aux
jeunes explique puis je les au début
c'est parce que justement les personnes
comme on peut en voir ça c'est ma plus
de chance d'entreposer l'excédent
d'énergie au mauvais endroit dieu
que les personnes infectées
la médication qu'on adresse poser piété
quand on fait de l'épidémiologie pont
fait de l'inférence causale on se dit
est ce que si je modifie un facteur je
vais avoir un effet sur le la haute
comme de santé qui qui m'intéresse pour
les maladies cardiovasculaires pour le
pour le cancer pour les maladies
neurodégénératives on n'a pas ces études
le problème en pôle pour le diabète j'en
ai une étude qui a été publié une
vingtaine d'années qui s'appelait le
dail bêtise pure veine programme russe
qui avait fait ce qu'ils avaient pris
les gens qui étaient à risque de
développer le diabète qui on voyait déjà
qu'il y avait ce qu'on appelle une
intolérance au glucose ou un déjà dit
rollin avec avec leur insuline puis ils
ont mis sur justement une diète ou est
ce qu'ils y perdaient du pop y faisait
plus de sport ça marche et ça ça
diminuer l'incidence du diabète 2 58%
mais ce qui est intéressant dans ces
études là aussi c'est quelqu'un on offre
mais on a regardé les chiffres depuis
quand je dis aux poumons ne s'est laissé
les gens qui ont fait cette étude le
bailleur marque y avait comme une espèce
de sweet spot de perte de pau piste et
c'était je pense que c'était 5 km et
fait ces gens le pays perdait à peu près
5% de leur poids corporel
hand 5 et 10% je pense dans la peau
corporelle c'est fake si tu pèses je
sais pas une suprise 300 olive puis du
super 5 à 10% tombeau corporelle bâtisse
et 15 20 est livré avec selon d'échardes
indice de masse corporelle le vtt en
situation d'obésité si les enquêtes et a
perdu un peu de poids pis tu lui a
surtout perdu au mauvais endroit parce
qu'il le message qui est importante je
le faire du au bon endroit c'est sa
basket on se dit ok ouais mais comme
achever pour perdre le tel type de
graisse passe bien le côté possible de
se ses clientes remettre à manger puis
quand n'a bougé exactement si c'est la
graisse dans le foie c'est la grèce dans
tes muscles sans qu'il s'en vend promis
parce que battait réservoir de grèce le
tai chi qui sont bénéfiques le haut
niveau sous cutanée le bâti ça c'est
beaucoup plus difficile ans
à faire changer petit pour ça aussi que
quand on parle des standards de beauté
bâtisse et c'est un type de graisse qui
vaut majoritairement à être
présent chez les femmes qui vont être
les premiers à wright victime de deux
vaches et ming pei de stigmatisation
puis bassin type de graisse kiki pas
nécessairement néfaste pour la santé
donc c'est important de garder ce que de
garder ça en tête aussi
ça fait ça fait 20 ans qu'on sait seul
qu'on sait tous qu'on dispute en taule à
peu près sur la génétique puis sur
l'impact que ça peut que le poids peut
avoir pourquoi est ce qu'encore
aujourd'hui on va à l'épicerie puis il
ya des magazines
qui sont complètement out day trans par
absolument sûr construit un truc minceur
pour pour madame x ou tiens pourquoi est
ce que c'est encore le qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est parfaite la la la
transition
conseil puis là le public général puis
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils aient pas de
législation autour de juste quelque
chose qui est aussi faux comme comme ma
famille aussi néfaste pour la santé
publique mais parce qu'on fait de
l'argent avec 16 points mais on fait de
l'argent que les cigarettes au site il
ya quand même eu une espèce d'efforts de
phare et l'on veut on va cacher ça au
moins et puis on va mettre des poumons
meurtrissures les tableaux de boire le
thé mais en termes de santé publique on
n'a jamais parlé même de cette culture
absolument néfastes le oui je suis
entièrement d'accord avec toi et côté
l'industrie des produits puissante et
des moyens mêmes égards sens c'est une
industrie de plus que soixante dix
milliards dans le manque de three weeks
tintin ils s'en vont nulle part pied en
plus ses envies c'est souvent quand on
parle d'alimentation d'obésité de
bien-être on veut souvent à l'extrême
c'est de comparer ce à 10 cigarettes
font ce qu'il faut faire attention un
peu aussi le parce que dès qu'on
parle d'alimentation s'il faut
s'alimenter trop froid c'est pas comme
ça mais non faut s'alimenter bien 3 pour
passer ça c'est pas comme si trois fois
par jour fallait prendre la décision de
ne pas fumer
puis évidemment les filles de
l'alimentation puis du tabac sur la
santé ça se compare même pole dance est
tellement mais il faut à payer de fumée
puis il ya aucun bénéfice
aux au tabagisme plus juste des
conséquences bien effectivement comme
tulle 2 comme tu l'a bien dit
présentement il ya de plus en plus de
législation qui sont qui sont sévères
plus de taxes qui ont été faites quoique
en pensant au québec on a un énorme au
rattrapage de taxes affaires sur les
produits du tabac quant aux autres
provinces le wes et c'est absolument
ridicule à quel point c'est l'enjeu
c'est la façon la plus facile de
diminuer la consommation de tabac à
l'échelle la population ben c'est
d'augmenter les taxes qui nous on y va
on accuse vraiment retors et pression'
ce raisonnement est des fois ça peut
même passer du simple au double taxe le
donc
c'est ça plus pourquoi on le fait pour
jean séance c'est totalement
incompréhensible c'est sûr que même là
où ces mêmes d'argent d'or a atteint
absolument c'est on pourrait tellement
step up notre game le ce sur la lutte
aux produits du tabac c'est incroyable
donc voir pour ceux puis je me suis
tendu un peu là dessus mais pour qu'on
dise pourquoi est ce que c'est encore
rapport le fait que ce soit un
industriel soit 1,10 milliard $ bas et
c6 parce qu'on peut pas décemment dire
que
kelly messages qui sont
véhiculées sont faux sont trompeurs mais
seront peut-être pas nécessairement faux
puis si on voit des messages qui sont
qui sont mensongers ben le il ya des
façons de les dénoncer aussi le métier
je voudrais yo yo yo il ya quand même
peu de gens qu'ils forment le chèque il
ya des organismes qui exclut le seul à
l'autre le métier je veux dire son liant
sont pas leur premier rodéo le ces
compagnies le ghsr c'est quoi les
messages qui vont avoir un effet qui
vont
sans nécessairement dire que c'est
trompeur mais il ya quand même beaucoup
de ces messages le qui sont extrêmement
problématique pour pour la santé mentale
de nos jeunes surtout le don que ce soit
qui aurait une petite révolution à faire
là-dessus en servant d'accord avec toi
puis c'est vraiment fort chez un
séquenceur et en santé publique puis
quand tu fais ton épicerie aussi de voir
ça ces messages le physique
j'ai vraiment de la
mousserie puissent voir les unes de
magazines du père défunt et lives avec
l'insomnie les a ni excuse avec
l'hypnose ou des choses comme ça samedi
c'est plutôt le contre
mais mais non c'est ce teaser cccc pas
démontrée scientifiquement puis 6 il
faut aussi ne te ya pas de vieux potes
d'études là dessus mais
j'aimerais ça porte de manière presque
l'impression qu'on arrive toujours avec
des nouvelles solutions autres que
celles là on avait trouvé un lockheed tu
vas boire un jus de céleri par jour le
seul ça va marcher ou août votre netease
et ça ça va marcher tandis que dans font
la solution mon assise depuis longtemps
c'est
bien manger en guillemets qui comme on
dit et on mangeait plus faisait fruits
et légumes possible demande aidez-nous à
manger d éviter les produits transformés
pu bouger c'est juste que ceux ci il
l'industrie andré le lobby du brocoli
faut manger plus de broccolis pour le
plus bruyant lancé tandis que la
compagnie de jus minceur décidé se
doteront faire de la pub et renonce à
faire entendre quand justement c'est ce
en un jour dans la recherche de réponse
mais la réponse est soutenu depuis ce
toujours aux écoutes moi je suis
d'accord avec toi puis je suis toujours
aussi
surpris et épaté par l'ingéniosité des
des gens qui qui font de l'argent avec
des choses comme le jeune c'est comment
tu peux faire de l'argent avec le jeune
et dernier temps maintenant on entre
alors que tu sais la dernière diattara
mode qui te piquer que riad qui aurait
images etc évidemment par rapport par
rapport aux autres d'y être nommé
effectivement tout le pays ils
réussissent à pas de l'argent quand il
m'avait écouté avec sortie c'est dire à
quel point acquis à quel point il ya de
l'argent à faire avec l'insatisfaction
corporelle unis puis si tu le dis la
solution
la solution c'est quoi mais c'est quoi
le problème la question c'est quoi le
problème qu'on veut qu'on veut régler
csu problème du poids ou c'est le
problème de la santé de la population
moi je pense que c'est ces deux
questions qui sont complètement
différentes qui on n'a pas beaucoup de
bénéfices à avoir en santé publique si
on fait juste ciblé le pro leproux alors
qu il ya tellement de gens qui est de
plus en plus de jeunes sikhs sont en
mauvaise santé le teaser le diabète de
type 2 ces maladies qui vont en
progression dans dans notre société
métier si on avait des politiques
publiques vraiment plus avec plus de
mordant pour
démocratiser l'accès à une alimentation
faire en sorte qu'on arrive en 2022 avec
un aménagement urbain qui qui est
propice à l'adoption de saines habitudes
de vie mon frère d'énormes gains là tu
plutôt que de d'envoyer des messages
justement directement au consommateur ce
qui qui sont restés mattison aussi sûr
sûr sûr le pool donc moi c'est là c'est
là dessus que j'ai envie de me battre
pour qu'on pour qu'on change nos
politiques publiques pour compromettre
la santé des gens
puis la santé de l'environnement aussi
parce que ça vaut main dans la main en
plus
cc c'est clairement démontré que plus on
fait de transport actif plus on est en
santé plus la planète et en santé que
plus on se tourne vers une alimentation
de qualité et végétales plus on fait de
gains pour la santé publique la santé de
la planète cefic cessé de se battre
contre les quand les forces de
l'immobilisme lucky qui épie d'appui de
cibler limon action pour pour qu'on soit
capable de bien s'alimenter puis de
laisser une planète à nos enfants qui
qui va être plus habitable fonctionne en
toile les pistes de solution c'est plus
un travail en pis en modifiant
l'environnement autour des individus
plutôt que de sites conscientiser puis
de deux des occupants bilizim dans un
sens essayer de deschamps le
comportement chez l'individu ça va être
plus pardies rendre justement les
aliments sains accessible promouvoir
dans la société plus d'activité physique
cd le rendre plus accessible et ça fait
40 ans qu'on dit aux gens d'arrêter de
manger puis perdu pour pour maigrir et
on aura si ça marche pour le vin est
temps d'explorer quelque chose d'autre
c'est joseph les la progression des taux
d'obésité le est dans tout les pays du
monde ok depuis les années 80 les années
90 c'est arrivé dans tout les pays
évidemment ça au début aux états unis
bas au canada au royaume-uni en europe
mais là c'est partout le petit fake
c'est comme si tu savais à peu près tout
en même temps le tfc comme si tout le
monde se dit basescu a moins la saine
alimentation et l'activité physique ça
m'intéresse [ __ ] et c'est pour ce qui
est à relever c'est des changements dans
notre environnement dans l'offre
alimentaire dans les transports qui qui
a changé qui a changé par tous avec les
conséquences que cela a eu sur notre
santé fait que sans changement
l'environnement que con qu'on va
améliorer la santé des gens les petits
on parle de génétique depuis tantôt
depuis mousse que ce que j'entends
souvent comme message c'est the wham et
si la génétique ça a pas d'effet sur ton
peau parce que ben il ya 40 et on avait
les mêmes gènes pis
c'est tout le monde tellement inspiré
aujourd'hui on a exactement les mêmes
chaînes du même john cena dénombre pas
évalué à 40 ans c'est un environnement
qui évolue c'est vrai puis ça a été
étudié aussi le tir
une cohorte en norvège aussi que qui est
que de l'adn chez des gens qui vivaient
dans les années 60-70 qui il démontrait
que prenant que dans ces années là aussi
le l'obésité ça existe et le thé josette
pons est moins élevé qu'aujourd'hui
métier josé des personnes grosses il y
en a pas mal toujours eu lieu dans dans
l'époque moderne puis ce qui démontrait
c'est que le fait d'avoir une
prédisposition génétique impro élevé ç'a
influencé ton pot mais pas autant que
souhaité mais là vu qu'on est dans un
environnement qui qui catastrophique sur
le plan de l'accès à la nourriture de
qualité puis aux transports puis à
l'activité physique ben c'est les gens
qui ont une susceptibilité génétique
avoir un pro élevés qui sont gros
aujourd'hui avec le triste c'était pas
du cep civilité génétique à avoir un
poids élevé notamment des années 70 de
démence aujourd'hui vizille autre visée
c'est vraiment des changements dans
notre environnement qui ont réveillé
cette cep sibilité gêné de ces clubs
puissants changement en changeant notre
environnement aussi qu'on va avoir des
des bénéfices je pense pas qu'on va être
capable de
changer la
trajectoire du portier realistic mans le
pti je veux dire des gens des personnes
gosse
c'est présentement il ya en a au pit et
il va en avoir dans dix ans il va en
avoir dans 21 pays vendredi joseph je
vous rejoint pas comment on pourrait
freiner la progression des taux
d'obésité il apparaît que ça va changer
mais ça va prendre des changements
vraiment important petit je me dis aussi
c'est ce qu'on veut c'est quoi le ccc
tuque les gens soient m'en soucie que
les gens soient en santé d'ailleurs un
pays dans lequel lire les lits taux
d'obésité lions ont régressé dans les
dernières années tous avaient une
réponse un flip tenté quelques jours
pays scandinaves
n'ont tout venezuela
était la bonne une crise économique
c'est
bon les gens meurent
de faim ce qu'on veut
c'est ce qu'il faut vraiment et miser
sur ce relais sur la santé puis peu
importe les résultats que ça ressorte
sur notre peau et puis justement tête en
parallèle aussi travaillé pour faire un
environnement qui pue saif pour les les
personnes grosses aussi paraître et de
stigmatiser puis de dire à quel point
tous les problèmes de santé qu'on a
c'est de la faute du xxe lors que cdc
des enjeux sociaux beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus profond que conques est
simplement ce quel poids d'une personne
oui il ya quelque chose qui me frappe
chaque nouvelle épicerie c est à quel
point premièrement les allemandes
transforme était bourré de succès c'est
omniprésent piété souvent c'est vraiment
destiné aux enfants par exemple serial
est floue safer liszt et si comme pi
pi de l'idée que ce soit répandue pis
normal de comme
se nourrir de chaque matin de donner à
nos enfants c'est commis quelque chose
pour moi qui me dépasse pis ça me fait
réfléchir t on à paris iv aussi de
l'aimantation intuitive sepideh d'aidé
d'écouté csdc ces listes ne sont qu'à
d'écouté où ce qu'est ce qu'on a envie
de manger du succès
puis dans un contexte parce que autant
d'aliments
tellement transformé qui sont faites
pour être super est retiré dans un sens
est ce qu'on peut vraiment se fier à
nous à nous un signe aux ânes aux envies
corporels aux signes ou notre corps nous
envoie qu'un qui ces choses là qui sont
pratiquement de la cocaïne le jeu repose
quasi la glatt
effectivement le faisait parce qu'il
faut quand même faire attention quand on
parle
de l'addictif puis dissoutes et je pense
qu'effectivement je le sais moi même
noté joseph quatre manches des produits
ultra transformer des fois le disque et
aime vraiment le sat procure du plaisir
il ya de la dopamine qui relâchait dans
ton cerveau puis ça procure du plaisir
c'est sûr et certain affecter les
produits transformés oui ça contribuer
au gain de poids ou si le pire au
développement de toutes sortes de
problèmes de santé métier josé soit
parce qu'on est brooks avait justement
dire qu'on qu'on mange les produits
transformés ni si le
tfc démontré aussi que dans des essais
cliniques randomisés quand on est de 20
en
un choix de prendre des produits ultra
transformer ou des produits plus frais
attendre d'avoir tendance naturelle à
avoir à livrer les produits transformés
puis aussi en termes de calories ben on
va manger plus de calories peut-être que
dans une société mind savoir aller
jusqu'à 500 calories de plus infectés
c'est sûr que l'omniprésence des
produits le transformer ça contribue à
la détérioration de la santé des gens le
successeur de certains métiers en même
temps je disais il ya plusieurs
personnes qui travaille vraiment fort
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
créatives pour
diminués justement la télé marketing ou
la présence des produits transformés
mais en même temps c'est pas quelque
chose ça va pas disparaître de nos
tablettes de l'épreuve ultra
transparente où les queues en toute
transparence si j'espère que non parce
que ça me procure du plaisir quand même
l'outil mois dans un monde où est ce que
je peux plus aller panier mais miss
vicky et chez pasqualetti comme ses
poches mais quand même c'est quand c'est
fait avec une connaissance de cause la
procure du plaisir qu'ils font à fort
hills et puis pour ceux qui était joseph
n'importe-quel cliniciens vous dire que
s'il ya pas de y'a pas d'aliments
interdits par exemple si j'osais si toi
tu aimes seuls immigrés qu'ils le bâti
mangent à leur faim en mangeant toute
l'histoire bâtir est prête pour le fake
c'est sûr qu'on a tous des choses à
faire dans notre quotidien pour
améliorer la qualité notre alimentation
mais comme je dis c'est ici
si on fait juste tous un peu améliorée
surtout les gens qui partent de loin
reliant m'ont un peu plus pour dans la
mesure du possible parce que comme je le
dis le plein d'enjeux sociaux
économiques entrent en ligne de compte
baa et et on va faire des gains
importants pour notre santé de l'hôtel
je vous aurais je pense je pense que
c'est ce personnes souhaitaient que des
aliments qui nous procure du plaisir
disparaîsse ddd tablettes n'ont plus de
toit santé jose heures on vit dans une
société libre et démocratique le donc
voilà
je j'ai l'impression aussi qui est un
haut pourcentage de de pollution en ce
qui a trait à la nutrition dans surtout
avec les réseaux sociaux est ce que
dumont avec des millions d'abonnés qui
prône dire de joueurs le trois fois par
jour le tir puis
j'imagine que ça aussi c'est vraiment un
enjeu important l'accès à l'information
de qualité en ce qui a trait à la
nutrition pour la population globale
puis je comprends pas pourquoi autre que
nous dans notre parcours scolaire ça n'a
jamais été abordé la notion jamais
jamais jamais on ne parlait de on a fait
un macaroni à la viande en économie
familiale mais ben c'était en deux
séances de coupe des boxeurs le fait que
j'en savais rien à voir puis puis sinon
peut-être dû voir grossièrement le guide
alimentaire canadien mais encore là le
guide en plus à l'époque il était limite
le tir pendant un peu plus tu es du côté
sportif on découvre du sportif parce que
nous on faisait de la natation mais
sinon j'ai l'impression que l'accès à
l'information qualité c'est justement ça
manque complètement le web et je suis
d'accord avec toi mais c'est parce qu'à
un moment donné le alimente
l'information c est disponible chez les
pee les gens le savent un peu mais ce
carré c'est que le site information là
est un peu bas et je le dis non le guide
alimentaire canadien
c'est pas sexy le nom je veux moi je la
chaque fois que je parle à quelqu'un
pimenté qu'est ce que je leur ai demandé
ce qui rend le sig le tcc ci dessus les
recommandations du guide plus de fruits
plus de légumes bonduelle et le coeur
mangé plus de produits agréés entier sa
tournée par les les protéines zénith les
protéines végétales mans j'ai eu mon et
transformer l'information et leur
formation et l'homme et il n'y a pas
d'argent à faire avec ça les influence
en feront pas d'argent avec ce accuse
personnes j'ai vu beaucoup d'influencé
sans problème c'est le fier que le guide
alimentaire
non effectivement fait
énormément d'argent aussi à faire avec
l'idée de la dette dans un espèce de
troubles de l'opposition aussi le t2 de
prétendre le contraire de ce que le
consensus scientifique dit saad amène
énormément de followers que ça peut
devenir extrêmement payant fête s'est
rendu à la justice et être la régulation
des médias sociaux le médecin de machin
je me lance pas là d'un tournant dans
nos dossiers
avant avant qu'on termine peut-être que
te re pas la réponse mais on parle
tantôt de santé cardiovasculaire puis
plus portes du pur complètement le jeu
m'avait complètement ailleurs puis moi
je fais beaucoup beaucoup de sport le
secours énormément puis je veux faire
des ultras faisant fort puis y'a pas une
semaine qui passe sans qu'aion mes
proches qui m'envoient des études
récentes qui sortent comme de quoi aller
en excès dans l'activité physique peut
avoir des répercussions négatives sur la
santé cardiovasculaire est quelque chose
sur lequel tu peux te prenons aussi un
peu bas je peux essayer je voudrais
premièrement largement je tombe sur
paris j'ai beau et je veux se passait
réellement
vraiment je pense qu'on aurait quelque
chose il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
font des infarctus par manque
d'activités visés que par excès d'actifs
des visées que nous il va faire un tour
sur les terres gdt coronarienne le coût
du travail donne exactement exactement
donc il faut relativiser
effectivement il ya des études qui ont
été faites surtout avec de l'imagerie
cardiovasculaires qui ont été faites qui
démontre que chez certains athlètes de
haut niveau il y aurait peut-être un peu
plus de calcium dans
dans leurs artères coronaires le plus
souvent en corée elle le calcium aux
événements cardiovasculaires ses matons
suprend des gens
notons ce jeu produit promettront dix
mille personnes en quarante et cinquante
ans un des bon prédicteur d'aidé
médicale d'urgence clair c'est la
condition qu'ils respirent at war 1 par
les devants tôt mais un dépôt pire aussi
c'est de regarder le calcium qui me
présent dans theater un coup qu'on le
dise oh faut faire attention aussi parce
que chez les gens par exemple qui vont
prendre des médicaments pour baisser le
cholestérol
ça va diminuer leur risque de faire un
infarctus mais ça va peut-être un peu
augmenté ou s'il calcium sont pense que
quand on chantait le juge marc ange
blanc dans la pathophysiologie
l'athérosclérose le mais c'est toi qui
me pose est qui
et qui pis quand on regarde en détail le
qu'est ce qui dans la plaques
d'athérosclérose doit souvent c'est du
cholestérol cdc des molécules
inflammatoires et des cellules
inflammatoires puisse s'assemble ça
semble en fait disparaître quand on
prend des idées
des statuts des pilules pour le
cholestérol puis on pense que ce serait
peut-être la même chose aussi avec
l'activité physique des fois c'est comme
un espèce de mécanismes de guérison des
des plaques d'athérosclérose que tu vas
voir soit au niveau ton artères
carotides yens août et artères
coronaires donc ce n'est pas une semaine
des farces pour la santé ceci dit ou si
c'est sûr que
d'un autre côté citant un risque
génétique un avoir une en arrêt cardio
respiratoire
des fois on
est susceptible it et génétiques ne
s'exprimera pas tant que pas mise dans
une situation comme par exemple avec le
sport d'endurance extrême à répétition
le ca peut être réveillé déçu
possibilité génétique dans ce cas le
fixe pour ça que bat il ya toujours du
du personnel médical sur les sur les
sodas marathon puis depuis le trop petit
sur le fait que les gaffes activement le
médecin est ce que c'est un enjeu de
santé publique non est-ce que
puis je sais pas c'est quoi les
recommandations non plus pour un pour
les athlètes le métier je pense que
plusieurs beaucoup de recherches à faire
là-dessus aussi pour caractériser le
profil génétique des gens qui vont avoir
un arrêt cardio-respiratoire sur les sur
les ultra trail par exemple mot ce
serait quelque chose que j'aimerais
vraiment avoir que je trouve vraiment
fascinant mais je vois laisser ça
quelques le doigt
merci infiniment est venu faire le
beurre et merci à l'invitation de 10 par
an plaisait et merci beaucoup
à acheter du contenu excellent tu as
tout un podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois et vous avez les
podcasts en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts avoir pouvoir avoir
une avance quand vous à l'étude de la
dynamique entre les amys tout le temps
avons une avance sur les jobs en avance
ou des centres de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le ch
et que le podcast unis voulaient nous
entendu davantage on fait des encore
moins de filtres à préchac podcast avec
là on vient de finir de tourner le
podcast on vend josé on va chill et
nicole non nicolas hulot maintenant
évident comme un fils travaille à place
de taza taille est là mais on jason par
la conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais
ce si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur têtu il faut s'abonner abonnez vous